turning up at what used to be their
former home to witness now its complete
destruction in these latest earthquakes
in the first two weeks ago Yusuf us took
says he was rescued from this building
after an hour and decided to come back a
week ago to retrieve valuables in spite
of the danger
yes it was risky but these were things
we couldn't leave behind valuables like
identity cards and documents he didn't
know that three people had been killed
here the night before while also
retrieving their possessions this is
what his building and the ones
surrounding it looked like after the
first quakes the video was taken by
another Resident who was also planning
on coming back to retrieve possessions
but says he knew with the strength of
Monday's Quakes that the building
wouldn't survive
I don't think anyone can ever plan
anything after things like this happen
soldiers who've been stationed here for
the past week have been describing to us
how these latest Quakes have completely
transformed this one street yet again
some buildings that had already been
damaged have been further pushed over to
one side others that were close to
collapse now just piles of rubble for
cities like antakia these Quakes have
added to the suffering and the misery
people are already enduring Bill L and
his family now share this one tent with
another family
when the Quakes came he said they had to
comfort their terrified children
it was like we were out at Sea we were
being hit by waves coming from one side
to the other
the people in this corner of
Southeastern turkey having to relive the
nightmare that began for them two weeks
ago Rob McBride Al Jazeera antacia